we have a voicemail number which you can
call anytime
the number is 2192 davidp here
is just an absolutely delightful caller
saying my metaphor about crawling over
broken glass to vote for biden
she says it literally applies to her
take a listen to this
hi david this is your fan in rural
florida who can only get you on free
speech tv
i just wanted to tell you that when you
said some people would crawl over broken
glass to vote
i burst out laughing not because it was
funny
but because you were describing me to a
t i already voted by mail in my primary
because
i'm 68 years old and i've been stress
eating for four years
so i'm likely to die from the virus but
now
i intend to wear double masks and turn
in my ballot to vote in person
nothing will stop me from voting against
trump
i just hope beyond hope there are enough
of us
keep up the great work david thanks what
a caller
what a caller just absolutely fantastic
and
you know there's the debates over who's
motivated which party is more motivated
or less motivated or what
it's going to come down to individuals
like
our terrific caller who say
i'm going to figure out how to vote
and whether i'm figuratively crawling
over broken glass
uh which includes crawling uh getting
around the landmines of voter
suppression that are being placed out
there
or literally crawling over broken glass
or what maybe
uh you know understaffed and and
under-resourced polling places or
whatever the case may be
wearing two masks etc uh she's going to
figure out how to vote and that's
ultimately what this election is going
to come down to we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today
there's a call from pediatricians to end
these
active shooter trainings that have
become very common in schools
and their argument is that the trainings
do relatively little
if there is actually an active shooter
it's such a chaotic situation that the
trainings really don't do much but the
fact that the trainings are happening
may be traumatizing to students and
maybe causing them
to live in what is still statistically
an irrational fear given the low
likelihood of an active shooter scenario
i want to talk about that um the cdc
has also removed its 14-day quarantine
guideline for people coming back from
out of state or overseas
and i want to talk about why and whether
it's a science-based decision
or a politically based decision we are
also going to hear about more
of the protests that are re-erupting
uh we're going to hear from lawyers
we're going to hear from protesters
it's a crazy situation that is again
developing i don't really know that it's
getting the attention it deserves and
we're going to spend some time on that
on today's bonus show so two ways to get
instant access to the bonus show number
one become a member at joinpakman.com
number two become a patron at
patreon.com
david pakman show and then reminder you
can join me tonight at quarter past
eight 8 15 p.m eastern for night three
of the republican national convention
i'll be streaming live
on youtube and on twitch i will see you
then